[Music]
the streaming service disney plus can
look forward to an addition soon
mend is the new hawkeye series which was
dominated by some rumors in the past
days
among other things it was reported that
hayley steinfeld known from bumblebee is
the preferred successor of the marvel
archer
many fans were pleased with these news
because in the past fans had already
expressed their wish for steinfeld to
play the role of kate bishop
as the side the illuminate and marvel
insider jeremy conrad report
the contract with her is supposed to
have been signed already although great
caution is recommended here
the luminer is a relatively new side and
hasn't really been able to make a name
for itself with exclusive relevations in
the past
also conrad is considered controversial
since he was often wrong in the past
especially regarding the coverage of
avengers and game
as you can see the situation is anything
but transparent at the moment and you
shouldn't trust the rumors that have
been well received by the fans 100
at this point in time it just remains to
be seen until we hear something familiar
from the official side or well
known industry magazines the second news
about the
mcu comes from the phase 4 movie thor
love and thunder
according to a report by both slash film
and natalie portman personally the
fourth
thor film will be shot by taika wait
titty in early 2021
the actress has revealed this via the
instagram account of her friend serena
williams she herself believes that
all the delays have given her more time
to prepare for the role as jane foster
concerning the plot
thorough love and thunder is supposed to
revolve around a romantic but also
wacky storyline as the name suggests
portman's character jane foster is
supposed to be more in the center of
attention and with christian bale there
is
also a new villain to look forward to
furthermore the popular guardians
are also supposed to make an appearance
in the new thor movie
their current release date for thor love
and thunder is february 11
2022 there are only very few films that
are scheduled to be released in cinemas
this year
one of them is dune as now reported by
trailer track the first trailer for the
desert thriller will be shown before the
cinema re-release of inception
on the occasion of its 10th anniversary
on august 14 2020
this is probably intended to lure fans
into the cinema as is not expected that
the trailer will be released online at
the same time
after all inception will be released in
cinemas on different days in different
countries
as soon as we have the trailer ready we
will of course notify you just
activate the bell and stay up to date
the expected release of the movies at
the end of the year on december 18
2020 besides june warner brother plans
also the release of wonder woman 1984
this year
also here the new trailer will be shown
before inception as part of a preview of
upcoming warner movies among them could
possibly be tenant and
conjuring three in addition fans of
inception can look forward to a few
minutes of bonus material in which
christopher nolan among others
will speak to the fans personally what
do you think about the idea of a
re-release of inception will the shown
trailers be good incentive for you to go
to the cinema or do you prefer to stream
from home
we're excited about your comments
as warner brothers reported a few days
ago the latest feature film tenant will
be first shown in international cinemas
before release in the usa can be
considered a release in 70 countries
including
australia the united kingdom and germany
is planned for august 26th
as we already suspected tanet will then
be released in the usa on september 3rd
this is intended to send out a signal to
the world that if necessary the
continuity of release dates will be
waived and that a pragmatic decision
will be made depending on the health
situation in the country which is why
the usa will be the loser in this regard
by the way
there's no release in china because the
country prohibits the screening of films
longer than 2 hours
so tenant with its 2 hours and 20
minutes is out for
now if the warner brothers approach
succeeds we can well imagine that the
same tactic will also be applied to
other releases in the future with the
first season of the witcher netflix was
able to impress fans and critics around
the globe
after the animated film nightmare of the
wolf was already announced fans can now
look forward to further additions to the
witcher universe
the new live action series will be
called blood origin and will include
a total of six episodes the content will
be a story set
twelve hundred years before the main
plot and will deal with the decline of
the eleven civilizations
the so-called sphere conjunction is also
supposed to play a major role this is a
special event in which
several parallel universes met and
merged into the world in which the plot
of the witcher main series also
takes place only through this
conjunction of spheres the humans are
supposed to have gained magical
abilities
which is why the first witchers were
formed responsible for the six part
series of the two producers declan
dibara and lauren schmidt his rich
who are also involved in the main series
anja zapkowski the author of the witcher
novels is also on board and will be
responsible for the content
unfortunately there's no fixed start
date at the moment but there are many
indicators that blood origin will be
released between the second and third
season which means a release date in
late 2021 or early 2022
is likely on the 20th of september this
year the annual
emmy awards ceremony will take place to
honor various television formats
a few days ago the circle of favorites
was further reduced as the nominations
now have been officially confirmed
one streaming provider stands out at the
top of the list all by itself
namely netflix the californian company
has a total of 160 nominations and is
therefore
undoubtedly throwing hbo off the throne
with its 107 nominations
the brand new streaming service disney
plus can also be happy
although it can't compete with the first
two providers in terms of the 15
nominations
disney plus has achieved something else
that is unique in its first year the
mandalorian was nominated as
best drama series the series with most
nominations again comes from hbo
watchmen can count 26 nominations
including best miniseries
and best actor in a leading role
immediately following with 20
nominations comes the amazon series the
marvelous mrs maisel which
already received the same number of
nominations last year
[Music]
you